shannen doherty reacts to the
heartbreaking news that Michael bublé's
three-year-old son Noah has cancer it's
hard ET chatted with the actress at the
American Cancer Society's inaugural
Giants of science gala on Saturday she
said quote I would imagine your child
having cancer is devastating as a parent
you're scared all the time because you
love him so much that you can't ever
ever think of a world without them I
think that's a real of every single
parent out there Shannon said the best
thing the singer and his family can do
is trust in their doctors and stay
positive
adding quote that positivity that
outlook on life that you can get through
something it actually does get you
through we're gonna fight and I'm gonna
take every day and make the most of it
the actress who was diagnosed with
breast cancer in February 2015 also gave
a moving speech at the event and her
words resonate more than ever now quote
courage is something that you gain and
it grows and courage is facing every day
and every obstacle one step at a time
courage is knowing that fear is not
going to find a solution Shannon also
accepted her award on behalf of all the
father's in the world who taught their
children to have courage